you
[Music]
we're going to get started we're going
to squeeze a lot into the next hour and
a half so I want to make sure that we
have time for all of our speakers and
then a panel so if you all could find
your seats that would be great great
well thank you so much for coming to
this session we're really excited to see
so many people in the audience and today
we're going to talk about the impact of
quantum computing on machine learning
and artificial intelligence so of course
the focus of the summit this year is on
the edge of AI and I would definitely
consider quantum computing on the edge
and thus it's definitely on the edge of
AI right so we're going to talk about
this cutting edge topic of quantum
computation we have three phenomenal
speakers with us today they're each
going to speak for about 20 minutes and
then we will go into a panel discussion
afterwards so please try to hold your
questions for the end and those can be
asked during the panel at the very end
of the session if you have a very urgent
question we'll take roughly one question
per talk during the session our three
our three speakers today first we'll
hear from Mattias Troyer Mattias Troyer
has been a professor at ETH Zurich but
actually recently in January joined the
quark team here in redmond as full-time
employees that we welcome matthias ahead
to Microsoft he's the winner of the
Raman prize for computational physics
he's a trustee of the Aspen Center for
physics and he his recent work has
really focused of course on quantum
computing the simulation of quantum
devices he's interested in HPC he also
has some very interesting projects on
ecology and looking at marine and island
life and simulating that so he's really
a computational scientist now more than
a computational physicist so we'll hear
from Mattias and then we'll hear from
Nathan weave who's a member of the quark
team here in red
Nathan is really a pioneer in quantum
machine learning he wrote the first
papers on deep learning algorithms how
to how to actually execute and train
deep learning models and Boltzmann
machines on a quantum computer and
achieve speed ups and he's also worked
on qubit characterization and
calibration and other areas of quantum
algorithms in particular in the
simulation of physical systems for
applications in quantum chemistry and
material science for example and then
we'll hear from Helmut cot scrubber who
is a professor in physics and astronomy
at Texas A&M he's really a computational
physicist and Helmut also received the
NSF early career the NSF Career Award
and we'll hear from helmet around some
quantum inspired optimization algorithms
that what one could actually run now in
advance of having quantum hardware so
let's start by welcoming matthias for
our first talk Thank You Christa we need
to switch name so I want to talk about
the quantum edge of this that contested
AI and when you look at computing let's
see you have to yeah which
yeah turn on the side it's off yeah when
your local convene the challenge has
been over millennia to get computers to
work and with we still haven't solved it
so I really need AI in my laser pointer
for next time but your cryptic the
computing started out with the engineer
click build think mega analog mechanical
devices to predict pick the positive
decisions chanty of the planet and the
moon going to classical mechanics a
digital ones electronic ones typically
supercomputers and now the next step the
edge of computing is quantum computing
that's why Microsoft softner turning a
pity invest in a project that sounds
like science fiction's but is something
that we can actually build something
that can really change computing and we
don't just work on the qubits the
hardware but we've over the full stack
we work on the first test and test test
and you get the certifications jump
devices the classical control the
runtime operating system the quantum
compilers for it the libraries on top of
it these algorithms and also the
applications in chemistry and possibly
this pocket here gates think of
detonated machine learning so it's a big
project and what's exciting here is that
one can really work on the full stack
which is quite rare in science nowadays
let me start just with a simple example
of what could be a qubit and how one can
use a qubit and you want to do something
already that's beyond what is possibly
classically namely how do you make a
random bit classical computing is
deterministic so theoretically in
classical physics it's impossible to get
randomness in quantum physics is very
easy what you take if you take light you
shine the light on to a two and again
semi-transparent
yeah so how the light goes through it
and how the light is reflected and then
they both hit me get the detector but
now let us not send the light beam but
let us send very little light and then
light is quantized into particles called
the photons so take a single photon and
the single photon here hits the same a
transparent mirror and what should they
do should it go through or not what you
do then if you ask Yogi Berra who said
when you come to a fork in the world you
have to take it so what the photon does
is it actually follows both paths and it
goes in the so-called superposition of
both values so those quantum particles
can be in two states simultaneously and
then in the end the hit the photo
detectors are there and now I want to
mention find out where is the photon and
of course when you look where something
is where this bodily is then it's only
in one place like here it's not in a
superposition we've never seen that and
so when you look at it then actually it
chooses one position randomly in this
case the zero and that's how we get a
random bit and this is a kind of the
minimal model or for the quantum circuit
it could be they can do and it's already
beyond what the classically one can do
so the basic idea is instead of a
classical bit there is either 0 or 1
like a light switch that is either off
or on a quantum bit can be in a
superposition it can be some amplitude
times the state 0 plus some amplitude
times the state 1 so can simultaneously
be 0 and 1 so while it lasts if it is
just 0 1 the quantum bit can be be
viewed as the state on a sphere up the
North Pole is 0 down the South Pole is 1
or it could point to the right that
would be the server plus 1 or could
point left that would be 0 minus 1 or
couldn't forward they would be 0 plus i1
and so it can be in any other
again superposition and then we look at
that
and sure thing already did that long ago
and said hey it's really weird
we've never seen that in nature and so
he formulated the Schrodinger's cat
paradox let's take a quantum state
that's here that's an atom that over
time decays and so after a while when
you describe it quantum mechanically
it's in a superposition of seven one
it's partially decayed partially not
decayed so it's in the superposition of
zero and one our quantum bit and now
we'll build the hellish device where
when the bit is one it triggers a hammer
the hammer falls down cracks open a vial
with acid the acid is k2 the cat dies
but now we describe it quantum
mechanically
so our qubit is in a superposition of
fear and one that means then the hammer
is in a superposition of being
simultaneously up and down so the flask
is in a superposition of being closed
and broken and thus the cat is in a
superposition of being dead and the life
have you ever seen such as shredding a
cat that at the same time is a
superposition of being dead in their
life jumping around and sleeping no and
that is just because like in the random
number case when I look at the cat it's
either dead or alive and it at that time
it randomly chooses to be dead or alive
so the challenge in building a quantum
computer is actually making eroding a
cat and macroscopic device that remains
in this like a super target position but
you cannot look at it when you look at
it then it's either dead or alive
so the approach we take is you want to
build the topological quantum computer
what we do for that is we take a state
here and that state is my qubit and you
can be either be 0 or 1 so the simplest
way is simply take one to one side here
one location that can have cereal
actions or one electron
but of course when the I can look just
look at it and then know whether there's
an electron sitting they are not so what
we now do is this doesn't appeal to
theory to be based on work cause of
finding a pizza
met the list now you're Michael yeah
Friedman who's the technical fellow
donor here you have to use Microsoft and
the idea is one takes this electron and
that's where the science fiction public
comes in and we split it into two
so-called Mariana particles so we split
apart this state into two new quasi
particle excitations and they are
located in such a device
now the magic is that looking at one of
these particles you don't know what the
state is but only together with the
other one can you know whether it's 0 1
so by splitting the information into a
non-local state you can hide it and
protect it so you can look at this here
and I do not destroy image reading a cap
so what can we do when you have that
with a single qubit I have two states
here and one with two qubits I have four
states 0 0 0 1 1 0 1 1 so when I have n
qubits the total of 2 to the N possible
states is all possible bit patterns of n
bits to simulate 10 cubits
I need 16 kilobytes of memory because us
to store 1,000 complex number that I can
calculate on my SmartWatch for 20 cubits
any 16 megabyte that will take
milliseconds on my smart phone for 30
cubits and it signified that needs a
laptop for T cubed and is 16 terabytes
that needs it with a large cluster when
I go to 50 cubits then it would need a
machine with 16 petabytes of memory we
may have the tool we don't have it yet
the world record is by binary system any
Thomas they are they are here
or the incident you stand up they have
the world record for negative simulating
qubits that any fortifies qubit
simulation using half a sister but the
pet take a bite of your memory on one of
the data that largest supercomputers in
the world so that's kind of what we can
still simulate then when you go to on
the fifty cubits then you clearly reach
the edge because for two hundred fifty
cubits you need more memory than there
are atoms in the visible universe so
when you get to that size then you have
a machine that you cannot simulate
anymore now the question becomes when
you have such an amazing G machine that
that's at the edge of the universe in
terms of the computing capability what
do we do with it and find them proposed
already that you can use that to
enormous ly accelerate many calculations
because these qubits can be in the
superposition of all possible states we
have one two three four five hands on
all possible inputs you can run a
program simultaneously on all these
possible inputs applications we see okay
first of all you could say beyond about
50-60 cubed it gets hard to simulate it
so you can do some random program that
you found that you can no longer to
simulate that's nice but what we rather
want you want to find the first
applications beyond that and we found
applications in chemistry we inserted
the circuit on ways to pick analyze how
their nature is just churning up it
breaks up the dnieper
chandâga molecule intuitive took the
ammonia which may lead the way towards
work what they are making up the cheaper
please verbalize in the future we may
use it with about a hundred cubits so
200 good cubits
we may use it to a specific design and
detecting new catalysts for carbon
capture the material science we may use
it for good for new materials the 50
superconductors dyes and more but for
this purpose here now when we have a few
more Cuba's I think we can do great
things in the upper New York a machine
learning and that brings me now to the
link between machine learning and
quantum computing that we'll focus on in
this session and the first application
is an AI edge for quantum science as I
did my postdoc last year approached me
and said let me use machine learning for
describing quantum space let me simulate
a quantum model using techniques from
together you after you have tested
machine learning a dozen oh yes you do
is go ahead but don't be too optimistic
because people have spent decades
inventing good description of quantum
system they spent years and the day they
have theorems showing what is the best
representation of the quantum system and
but it worth doing because it's
interesting and exciting and if AI is
really a hot topic so then he did and
there was quite surprised when he then
came and showed me that the simple
restricted Boltzmann machine with just a
few more wondering a hidden notes the
invisible ones can learn non-trivial
quantum states can predict the time
dynamics of quantum systems better than
the best know classical methods we have
the use is about the same memory so it
seems like can make many of the negative
talking of the New York architect
machine learning that just to get put
forth with the network is better than
what people have done manually before so
it's saying that now known that
has caused quite the change so many
people just try out to the beginnings of
new types of networks to see how machine
learning can help quantum science the
next way it helps is that when you want
to build this quantum computer now then
lots and lots of gates here and they
have to find the right voltages
everywhere to make it work to really
make this electron split into two major
honor particles and for that when you
just look at it and enter your switch on
that the qubit then it looks bad you get
scans like this this is that what you
wanted the function of the voltages is
some class come out that looks like this
so that a really nice and clean
structure and these structures will can
then sit on these edges and that's where
the qubits operates but first if you
find it with many controls and that's
where the oquawka team team works along
nerd you get using your pretty machine
learning to tune up those qubits for one
qubit you may still do it manually once
you go to 10000 it should be pretty
automating and that's where the AI gives
an edge to quantum computing
once we then have the quantum computer
then we go now to the quantum edge of AI
then we can use quantum computing to
help AI one way is we can do quantum
training we can train a classical
network using a quantum machine for
example a and need like a sampling
method
and be accelerated through quadratically
by quantum machines or you can train
even a quantum model instead of the
classic Network let's build a quantum
network and because the quantum machine
of the size of 250 qubits can no longer
be simulated by the universe this is
more powerful than any classical machine
and might be very useful for AI more
that will be the talk by tested negative
distance tempted be there was because
after to demean the session but that we
still need a quantum computer and it's
still a few years off until we have that
machine but until then already in the
last year's we looked at quantum
optimizers like the machines from near
d-wave in vancouver they built an
optimizer that works based on quantum
principles and looking at that one sees
that it allows to escape a minimum by
quantum tunneling magically through a
peg instead of climbing over eight and
so looking at the mechanisms how such a
quantum optimizer works or can realize
that hey I can mimic that classically I
can find ways of making use of similar
effects classically and that very
negative we can find classical
algorithms that are often orders of
magnitude faster than the known ones so
that on a simple PC you can run problems
that would have needed the quantum
machine or ever an egg a big Super Cup
to computer before that will be in the
last talk by the helmet after caps
carbine this session so wanted to show
you that with with quantum machines with
50 cubits we can build machines that are
more powerful than than any neoclassical
machine can be
started from AI we can use AI to help us
build a quantum computer then we can use
this quantum computer to get to better
fertility machine learning and build the
quantum AI but the meantime before we
have that we can already use what we
learn about quantum computers to build
this quantum inspired AI which are
classical methods that work on classical
character to attempted computers does
but what we have the ideas because we
solved a lot about quantum and so these
are the 250 areas of the next two talks
thank you great thank you
great well thank you very much everybody
for coming today I'm really excited to
get the chance to talk to you about
something that I really feel is kind of
at the forefront of machine learning and
artificial intelligence and in
particular what I'm going to be talking
about is the promise of quantum neural
networks so machine learning as I'm sure
you're no doubt aware it's really
changed the way I've changed the world
in ways that very few other emerging
technologies have with a few short years
we've gone from problems like considered
like designing a self-driving car which
once upon a time actually probably not
so long ago that really would have
required a major research team
specifically looking at just the problem
of driving a particular car under a
particular circumstance now we have
basically a large set of vehicles
including this one which one day I hope
down which actually use these solutions
in a commercial fashion and so this
really has profoundly changed the world
and this is powered by neural networks
as well as deep learning and so neural
networks are there I find them really
kind of amazing and I every time I look
at this I really think wow I wish I
could be that creative and maybe
actually that's something that people
were thinking about when they were
coming up with the first neural networks
which really tried to model of course
complex data in ways that are very
analogous to how the brain is of
generating correlations between things
and this actually ends up leading to
very interesting behavior where this
these results over here came by by
taking an image which I think with van
Gogh's Starry Night and passing it
through a neural network that seems like
it's got a disturbing propensity towards
aquatic animals as well as yeah marine
mammals but anyway sorry that point but
the point is is that these technologies
are here and they have really profoundly
changed the world I mean one of the ways
that I feel is really shows the kind of
strides that we've made in recent years
is also the alphago AI program which
took a problem like go which for you
and years and years was the domain of
humans no one had found an AI at all
that could even remotely compete with
even a decent human player until this
reinforcement learning based approach
came around which allowed them to make
up well if you excuse the joke a quantum
leap in the technology yes I'm glad I
didn't hear any laughter so the point is
is that we've really seen some profound
steps forward with the power of the
models that we have for data and our
ability to automatically process this
but then the question at the same time
though is this has been undergoing
there's actually been a major change in
when it comes to quantum technologies so
as Matias mentioned during his talk
we've realized that if we build devices
or computers that utilize the very laws
of physics in order to be able to
extract useful computations then we can
actually do some things we never even
thought possible so it makes a question
how do these two things intersect where
do they meet up and what can quantum
computing bring to machine learning and
this is still an ongoing question
there's a number of basic basic answers
to this thing and I think the simplest
thing that that I can summarize for this
is that if we can build a fast accurate
and scalable quantum computer then it
can profoundly revolutionize machine
learning in part by giving us better
ways of sampling giving us new models of
data and on top of that actually giving
us new ways of enhancing privacy for
data that we that we're already storing
and processing on machines so but the
way that we've actually looked at this
most in the literature is it from the
question of speed ups what machine
learning tasks can we run faster on a
quantum computer and there's an
ever-growing laundry list of things that
we know how to speed up from
classification using support vector
machines principal component analysis
approximate Bayesian inference you see
at the list going on and on and on now
there's one thing that you'll note if
you asleep sent from this laundry
list that I that I did at the top the
humble feed-forward neural network
interestingly neural networks are
actually very very difficult in many
cases to find good analog for on a
quantum computer the reason for this is
because at some level quantum mechanics
is a linear theory all the
transformations on vectors that we end
up getting from quantum mechanics is our
fundamental operations are linear and
that makes it actually very difficult to
represent the nonlinear activation
functions that we would want in a
feed-forward neural network and this is
actually stymied people for a while
coming up with nice natural
representations for these these networks
and so this is led it led us to focus
and this is what I'm going to be
focusing on this talk on Boltzmann
machines which are they're not their
work a class of recurrent neural
networks and I feel they're the most
natural way to think about what the core
of neural network could be and more
importantly what can bring the world so
Boltzmann machines solve very important
tasks like classifying what this image
is over here which I'm told as a cat by
the name of little bub all right believe
it might be pronounced little bub but
anyway the point is is that how the
neural network ends up working is you
take the image data and you copy that
image data down into these these visible
units down at the bottom and these these
which are known as neurons these
intermediate ones over here hidden units
are hidden neurons and we don't care
about the values that these take all
that we ultimately care about is the
distribution that's input and the class
that's output over here for
classification problems and so what we
want is we want you know two for it to
say that yes this is a cat or no it's
not a cat just based on these neurons
down at the bottom and we have various
weights that govern the interactions
between these and we're the task is to
tune the interactions between these
neurons in order to back
to my's the probability being right when
this device tells you whether it's a cat
or not so the way that we do this is by
tuning the energy for it so this is a
very physics based approach and it makes
sense in some ways that a physics based
model like the Boltzmann machine where
you're setting the energy should be the
most natural way to represent a neural
network on a quantum computer so the way
that we would do this is we would if we
wanted to train using a bunch of
training images we would take the image
and a label claw which is corresponding
to cat or not cat and we want to be able
to assign energies to this and then the
Boltzmann machine when you allow to
thermal eyes will give us a probability
distribution over these different images
depending on the energies so the ones
high energy will be strongly for a
favourite against and the ones with very
low energy will be favored so if we have
something that's the correct
classification like this is a cat and
this is not a cat though should
correspond to low energy configurations
the ones that are dreadfully wrong like
this cat being not a cat or the pseudo
cat being a cat are should definitely
not be favored so that's the idea behind
it we tune the interactions between the
neurons or it we represent it on a
quantum computer the qubits in order to
be able to actually mold this energy
landscape so the favorable things are
low energy and the unfavorable things
are high energy that's the entire
intuition behind it
okay so mathematically speaking the way
that we we end up representing this is
we basically apart from biases for the
individual neurons is we set the energy
of a configuration to just be the
product of the values of these neurons
so if we take these neurons just to be 0
or 1 then we multiply all of the values
of the neurons end up taking that are
connected to each other together and we
multiply those values by a weight matrix
these are free parameters that you pick
and what you want to do is you want to
use gradient descent in order to be able
to optimize this in order to maximize
the likelihood of you reproducing your
training data evidence
so the other connection that I feel is
really evocative at this ends up giving
is that you can view this energy as just
an energy operator but you can also
recast that in a different language you
can represent this energy function at
the top is actually a quantum mechanical
energy operator known as a Hamiltonian
and this is just a diagonal matrix that
stores all the energies that will be
given to every configuration up there
but it has a very nice form it's written
in terms of basic quantum operations so
we can just get something like this and
directly compile it to run on a quantum
computer because these are basically
fundamental quantum operations that
we're seeing here and that's one of the
other things that makes this really nice
for running on a quantum computer but
question is how do we go beyond this how
do we quantize this kind of very
classical model of it and why would we
want well one of the reasons is that we
really would like to get richer models
we know that quantum mechanics can't be
simulated by ordinary computers so why
aren't we trying to leverage this in our
quantum devices to build new models for
data that would be impossible currently
and also enable new machine learning
tasks that arguably don't even make much
sense alone in a quantum framework and
I'm going to be spending a lot of time
talking about specifically that new
things that ordinary neural networks
just can't do but these things can and
so to give you an idea about how we
could quantize this is we need to take a
look at the basic building blocks of
neural network training that the objects
we first haves we've got a data set this
data set tells us what correlate are
tells us what we should be trying to
reproduce for this neural network it
tells us you know the labels that are
assigned to different classes and what
we want to do is we want to try to
replicate those labels as well as
possible and so what we do is we say
okay the classical thing you have is
just that data set or distribution over
it
quantumly we imagine that being
represented is a quantum district
nation over a set of vectors classically
for a Boltzmann machine we have an
energy function that describes this
landscape that gives us effectively the
probability of the bolts machine
outputting some image that energy
function now turns to a quantum
mechanical energy operator again known
as a Hamiltonian and make it very
different from what we have any other
case these ones the quantum mechanical
objects don't need to be diagonal they
can be non diagonal and that's important
as we'll see in a sec the final thing is
is that we've got to consider some sort
of an object that we want to train an
objective function for the training that
we want to maximize and classically at
least for generative training what we
want to do is we want to minimize the KL
divergence I which is statistical
difference between the input
distribution over the training data and
the output distribution given by the
Boltzmann machine for quantum machine
learning there's actually been a lot of
debate about what the right thing to do
is and one of the our work realized that
actually the best analog to use between
this is this quantity known as a quantum
relative entropy which reduces to the KL
divergence in the right limit so this is
actually the natural way to think I feel
about how to generalize a Boltzmann
machine in a fully quantum setting and
so basically it ends up looking exactly
the same way on the ground what we do is
we build this network of interactions
between these individual qubits each of
which each interaction is given by a
particular weight and described not by
just an energy number but by and entered
by an energy matrix and what we want to
do is we want to tune all of these W sub
J's in order to do it and the idea then
is once you expose this quantum neural
network to the training stage we want to
just let it thermalize and then this in
this thermalization process make
approximate copies of the input to
States so the idea basically is that you
feed quantum information forward onto
this quantum neural network and it
learns directly from that quantum
information and furthermore can even
generate quantum states back out
classical neural networks cannot
generate quantum states and so that's
that's one of the things that I think is
really neat about this so the other
thing is classically with Boltzmann
machine training all we have to do to
set up the clutter to decide between
these classes of images is set the
energy we only have this energy
landscape to deal with if we look at
this from the perspective of a quantum
energy operator that's the same as
tuning the eigenvalues of that energy
operator but in a quantum land because
this thing is non diagonal we can also
change the eigenvectors of this and that
gives us selectivity we can aim these
models a lot better in order to suppress
or enhance particular patterns that we
see in this and that give makes this
model much richer even if we're not
interested in replicating quantum states
are learning from quantum states
directly ok so because because I felt
the need to throw some math in one of
the questions you might ask is quantum
states are complex right how do I figure
out how to tune all of these free
parameters in order to be able to
actually get it to maximize this
likelihood turns out that actually you
can derive an expression for the
derivative of the relative entropy the
relative entropy itself is actually
extremely hard to compute but you can
actually find its derivatives pretty
straightforwardly so by expressing but
simply because of the fact that this
quantum relative entropy ends up
depending on the logarithm of this
quantum state that ends up coming at
which is an exponential in this case so
because the logarithm and the
exponential kind of nicely cancel each
other out using the properties of trace
and do a Mel's formula you can go
through the calculus and then you end up
finding the derivative of the relative
entropy is just a really familiar form
it's the difference between the
expectation values over the training
data and over the Boltzmann machine for
the individual terms that you have in
your model it looks exactly like the
gradient does for the classical
and that's something that's really
amazing you can take everything that you
had in a classical case not really
paying attention too much about the
quantum mechanical details and the exact
same formula will tell you how to
optimally tune the quantum analog of
your Boltzmann machines in case you're
wondering if you want to be able to
estimate the gradient within air Epsilon
you've got M parameters the number of
samples that you end up needing to the
number of Boltzmann State preparations
and the number of times you need to read
your training data ends up scaling like
this and at least in terms of the
scaling with Epsilon this is optimal so
that's that's what we end up getting out
of this and if we take a look doing this
on a classical computer we just can't do
it the reason why is because of the fact
that this training process unless I make
restrictions on the Hamiltonian is
actually known as a bqp complete so what
we can do is we can actually be to be
hard technically but anyways the point
is is that we can simulate any quantum
computation using this method by cooling
a state down to a sufficiently low
temperature and so if we could simulate
this process classically then quantum
computers will be no more powerful than
classical computers which we strongly
believe is not true based on decades of
experience so and also separations in
terms of query complexity so that is
what we end up having so let's take a
look at what happens when we actually
try this experimentally now it's how we
have large scalable quantum computers
we're not going to be able to try this
on big data sets like NMS at present all
we can really do is validate these ideas
on small systems that can be simulated
using ordinary computers so here's an
example of what happens when I feed in a
two qubit quantum state into one of
these Boltzmann machines simulated on a
quantum computer you'll notice that
these quantum states over here look very
different at the beginning I chosen
randomly from the target states that
we're trying to learn using the quantum
Boltzmann machine but only after five
epochs in the gradient descent algorithm
you actually can't tell the difference
between them graphically so these models
are learning these quantum states
incredibly quickly and furthermore when
you just let them run they generated
these states so another thing that you
might ask is well how much richer are
these models what's a big if well again
until we have bigger systems we can't
know the full answer to this question
but in small examples we've compared
that what happens when we train the
classical Boltzmann machine to the
quantum Boltzmann machine with a
differing number of hidden units one of
the things that's actually kind of
interesting about it is we found that in
this case what happened is was we
started increasing a number of hidden
units we really actually didn't see a
systematic improvement in the accuracy
of these models over here
classical Boltzmann machine we did see
an impact of increasing a number of
hidden units which is expected entirely
but the thing that's actually kind of
surprising is that this there seems to
be a gap and we weren't able to actually
fully close this gap between the two
moths and on top of that the quantum
model isn't gaining its power just
because of the fact that it's got more
parameters this all visible quantum
model over here given by the blue blue
line actually has fewer parameters than
this dashed line at the top now
obviously there's more work that needs
to be done in order to give a full
comparison between these two but this
gives a confidence that this intuition
that the quantum models actually give
Richard models more data than classical
models is somewhat borne out by the
stand another thing that I think is
really kind of neat about this is that
it also gives you a way to learn
information about quantum states so what
we what we have is if we have a thermal
state coming in here and we want to know
what it is we can effectively just learn
this Hamiltonian HF care by using
Boltzmann training and figuring out the
weight we do this and it learns it great
after fewer than 100 steps we're at
Machine Epsilon for this which is
comparable to many alternative methods
that have been come up for idiosyncratic
reasons in the quantum literature we can
also use this in order to build an
associative memory so here i've trade
boltzmann machine with four distinct
patterns load it up with an address
qubit that tells you which one you want
to generate
then I fix that address qubit and get
the Boltzmann machine to generate lo and
behold it generates exactly those states
on demand so these both machines can
actually be really neat quantum memories
so in order to conclude to conclude
quantum computers can give really big
speed ups for classical machine learning
problems as we've seen quadratic are
better in in most cases but they also
enable fundamentally different types of
machine learning and also on top of that
they allow us to actually directly learn
off of quantum states itself and allow
us to understand at a deeper level what
machine learning and artificial
intelligence really means is we push
beyond the classical world that we're at
to the very edge of physics thank you
very much
[Applause]
you
all right good afternoon everybody is
this yeah so what I like to do today is
basically assume quantum computers will
not work for a long long time or fail
completely and then see well what do we
do now I'm going to illustrate this by
studying a currently working quantum
device and I refuse to call it a
computer which is a special-purpose
machine designed to actually optimize
problems and because I'm going to do a
little bit of an arms race I figured
I'll keep tabs on the left-hand side you
have the Planck constant equals 0 which
means classical approaches on the right
hand side you have a finite plant
constant which means quantum approaches
there's a bunch of questions you would
like to have answers to one of them of
course which I will address extensively
is what is the current status of quantum
versus classical optimization what about
quantum approaches for machine learning
here I'm going very specifically not
about what Nathan Biba discussed earlier
but going back to what you could do with
current available quantum technology and
then of course what I just said before
if quantum annealing or quantum
annealing as it is being done right now
fails
can we still benefit and coming back to
the words of materials used I'd like to
just mention think quantum inspired now
the results I will show you where that
with a bunch of guys at Texas A&M that I
work with the world as well as some
other folks and I like pop-up video way
back when in grad school and since Chris
is here and unfortunately didn't make it
to the photo of figure I'll just pop
them in there good why do we need
quantum annealing and the answer is
simple it's optimization there's a lot
of optimization problems out there I'm
willing to say that optimization is
ambiguous pretty much anywhere in all
branches of science and also industry
and to give you an idea we can pick just
a handful of optimization problems for
example constraint satisfaction problems
these are boolean formulas you want to
basically find an assignment of the
variables that at the end computes true
you have a number of partitioning
problem you have basically a set of
objects you want to split it up into a
partition with equal weights it turns
out is a very hard problem to solve you
have minimum vertex covers which is
where do you place your guards in a
museum usually between two rooms because
then you can watch two rooms but while
the minimum number of guards turns out
to be again a very hard problem in one
of the optimization problems that most
people know which is a Traveling
Salesman problem where you want to know
what is the shortest route between
cities now these have a bunch of things
in common first of all they have what I
would call a very rough cost function or
energy landscape what I mean by that is
that you can have solutions that are
very similar however you would have to
have a very large rearrangement of the
variables to get from one solution to
the other in other words if you for
example have a traveling salesman tour
then a small perturbation to the
position of one of the cities could
cause a rearrangement of the tour that
is order of the number of cities you
have now these are very nasty problems
as seen from a physics point of view
because it means that your cost function
landscape has deep violet separated but
very very tall mountains another thing
they have in common is that they are
usually found in the NP class not only
that but if you were to look at the
typical time it takes you to solve these
problems
it is usually something very very
difficult so even on average you
basically have to bite your teeth out to
solve these problems and finally and
most importantly this however has to be
taken with a grain of salt
and it's only presented here to motivate
why people are building quantum
annealing machines with some overhead
you can map them on to what is known as
quadratic binary and constraint
optimization problems in other words
model massive potentially massive
overhead you can always cast any of
these problems and many more as such a
quadratic form where you have boolean
variables and you basically have an
interaction matrix q IJ that kind of
describes the problem you are trying to
solve and of course the goal here is to
find the minimum with respect to these
boolean variables in other words it's
important to have
good solvers for these things as well as
fast architectures I don't think I need
to convince you guys in the audience
that Moore's Law is slowly coming to an
end here is a picture of Moore's law you
can very nicely see that the transistor
count doubles roughly every other year
and so if you want to overcome this end
of Moore's law we basically have four
options at hand we can say fine
we'll just wait it out you know wait a
couple years and you'll have twice as
many transistors in your system but the
problem is that if you want to build
larger silicon based computers we're
going to encounter issues with power if
you wanted to build something that is
exaflop you will likely need of the
order of Giga watt power the other idea
is well can we develop faster silicon
technologies in the answer is not quiet
because we're reaching fabrication
limits and if I now add the clock speed
to this plot of Moore's Law you see very
nicely roughly since the year 2000 the
clock speed has more or less remained
constant so if you want to have any kind
of disruptive technology we have to
actually go beyond standard silicon in
other words come up with more clever
chip designs custom silicon type chips
or quantum architectures but more
importantly also invest in novel
algorithmic advances and here again I'd
like to just emphasize that the things
that we do at Texas A&M are basically a
mixture of physics quantum information
as well as some computer science good
now what is the current state of the art
in quantum optimization the current
state of the art it's funny material
shot the same device it's not
Antikythera but it is a machine that
basically something that I reinvented
2,000 years later these are
special-purpose analog quantum annealer
and these are machines that use quantum
effects to actually try to minimize
problems on these quadratic forms now as
Matias mentioned you can purchase
yourself such a machine it sets you back
roughly about 10 to the 7 dollars it's
made by giveaway of Systems Inc and what
is it it's a semi programmable machine
it's analog it is made out of in this
current Internet
roughly two thousand superconducting
flex qubits what this means is that if
your problem has two thousand variables
in principle you should be able to find
the optimum to your problem on this type
of machine controversial performance as
you will see in the next few slides in
more important more importantly I like
to emphasize that it's still a huge
technological feat building such a
device is highly non-trivial and I'm
sure that the Microsoft team that is
playing with my erna fermions is looking
at something that is an order of
magnitude even more complex than this
now what can this machine do as I said
before it can minimize these quadratic
forms post embedding and I will explain
what I mean with this onto the machines
fixed chimera topology what is this
thing well basically those quantum bits
are hardwired together just because it's
not easy to do plug-and-play in these
type of devices and they are wired
together in the topology you see behind
me in the top left you have these fully
connected bipartite KFOR for cells that
are then connected with their
neighboring cells so if you squint and
you treat one of these blocks of eight
qubits as a unit you have a
two-dimensional lattice of variables as
you can imagine this low connectivity
combined with the analog noise if
something that causes a lot of problems
the other issue with a lot of
connectivity is that if you were to try
to embed a problem it requires a fully
connected graph you would have a massive
overhead now how do these quantum
annealer optimize in the answer is
sequentially it turns out this is good
old German technology and for this let
me go back to the terminal analog on
which is simulated annealing about 7,000
years ago
the Germans figured out in the Melissa
era that if you take a chunk of metal
you heat it up and you cool it down
slowly you can remove imperfections in
other words coming closer to the optimum
and therefore work your metal better
build a better axe and wax them by even
harder okay now we can do the same thing
today on the computer it's called
simulated annealing
basically you start with your cost
function you add a temperature to it
it's a very high temperature sleeve
variables are continuously changing and
then you stochastic example the cost
function and sequentially you keep
reducing the temperature slowly once it
is term alized
and when you go with temperature goes to
zero you hope to actually find the
optimum to the problem the slower you
cool the better according to a theorem
by Gaiman and gammon if you cool
infinitely slow you will find the
optimum but this is by no means
practical now what is the issue that we
face if you use this technology on
problems with rough cost functions like
the ones that I showed you before it's
very easy to get stuck in a metastable
state the way this is typically overcome
is instead of doing a slower Neil you do
very many fast quicker meals in other
words you rain down on the landscape and
like that you hope to basically hit the
jackpot
how do quantum annealer work they
basically do the same except that the
term of fluctuations that you add your
cost function are replaced by quantum
fluctuations
it's a sequential method like simulated
annealing however you have an advantage
and the advantage is that since you have
a quantum problem now you don't have or
let me rephrase it you have basically a
quantum wave function that you slowly
reduce its quantum fluctuations meaning
that if you encounter a barrier that is
tall enough in your anneal you might be
able to tunnel across this barrier and
therefore find the optimum where a
tournament thermal type approach might
get stuck the way this is implemented on
quantum annealer is using a transverse
field this is for the experts in the
audience you start with your original
problem you see you have added variable
Z here you add a transverse field in the
orthogonal direction this induces
quantum fluctuations and then you reduce
the amplitude of these fluctuations
according to some protocol good now I've
told you why people want to build these
quantum annealer roughly how they work
and where you can get one which you
shouldn't
another question is can they do anything
useful and if we rewind about one and a
half years back there was a press
release by NASA and Google claiming that
this quantum device or
quantum inspired device might be 100
million times faster than classical
technologies let me show you the results
you're going to see a couple of these
plots what you see here on the
horizontal axis is the number of
variables in the problem to be optimized
and on the vertical axis you have the
time to solution in microseconds in
other words on average how long did it
take you to find the solution to a
problem for easier viewing I'm just
going to chalk in the 50th percentile so
that you can more or less see what's
going on and what you can see right away
is that the term of simulation has a
much steeper slope in other words it
scales
far worse than the quantum approaches
down here the d-wave machine and up here
you have quantum Monte Carlo or
simulated quantum annealing which
basically is take your quantum algorithm
and run it on current classical hardware
so you can see the scaling of this is
considerably better however we have a
massive offset now what are the problems
that they studied and this is just as a
side comment they took the native
lattice that these systems have this
chimera lattice and they took two of
these k4 four cells and wire them
together ferromagnetic Li what this
means is in the optimum all the
variables want to have the same value
but in addition to this they added to
their cost function a bias term and one
block had a stronger bias than the other
one meaning that when you thermally
anneal it's easy to get fooled into the
wrong state and land in a metastable
state if quantum mechanic works and this
thing is actually quantum you might be
able to tunnel through this barrier and
then find the true optimum now to make
this hard you take these what they call
weak strong clusters and you string them
together either with this red or blue
lines that you see up here what this
means is if you have a blue line two of
these clusters want to have the same
values in the optimum if they have red
lines they want to have opposite values
and as you can see this becomes suddenly
a very nasty constraint satisfaction
problem we call this this thin glass
backbone so let me go back to the
results if you now compare 10 to the 12
for thermal versus 10 to the 4
for the quantum machine you get your 100
million having said that you see that
the scaling of this thing down here and
actually one should look only at the
larger system size of the asymptotic
behavior is much flatter than for the
thermal emile what if we now take the
quantum algorithm run on classical
hardware the green line and run it on
better hardware think of for example
catapult and simulate the quantum
annealing or quantum Monte Carlo you
might be able to move this offset down
and find a much better optimization
technique so I would say better scaling
for d-wave and quantum inspired
algorithms so coming back to my
scoreboard I would give it a 1 0
needless to say this was displeasing for
me because I felt that there's many
other algorithms out there so we pulled
out the whole battery of methods that we
have account and we looked first at
algorithm tailors to the problem which
you see on top here we are actually
exploiting the structure of the problem
we know what the problem is made out of
and we abuse it in a simple example is
what we did this so called super spin
approximation where we said we know that
these weak strong clusters the logical
variables are unit blocks so what we can
do is we can just take the lattice and
replace it by individual large logical
blocks then you reduce the number of
variables and bam you solve the problem
but we also used algorithms that are not
tailored to the problems they're generic
methods that you can use for all kinds
of optimization techniques optimization
problems and we ran those we used first
population annealing Monte Carlo also
known as particle swarm method and we
also use the solver that we developed at
Texas A&M which is a mixture of what is
known as parallel tempering and I so
energetic cluster moves we thought well
this thing seems to work well let's set
it to max out competition last year and
then our first mission we actually want
again imagine what you could do if you
toss this thing on catapult just saying
good and then we compared to what was
done by the paper by Google and NASA
which is similar to me in quantum Monte
Carlo and the d-wave and now you see the
picture changes what you see here is fit
now aligned to
these individual scaling plots and show
the main leading scaling exponent in
other words what is the slope which
means that smaller slope is better
scaling and you see very nicely if I
color this in and I tossed a line across
the break-even simulated quantum of the
carlo here sorry similar to quantum
annealing here that within the
sequential realm of algorithms that
simulated annealing had so on quantum
does best but even when we use our own
solver that is not tailored to the
problem we massively outperform all
these other techniques of course this
here would almost called cheating
because we're abusing the structure of
the problem so I would say that any
speed-up is sequential at best and what
I mean is that you know we evened out
the score fast forward a year Indy we've
announced their machine with 2,000
cubits come accompanied by a paper that
was basically saying look our new
machine is so much faster than all the
others let me show you the results again
you see the wave the machine and quantum
Monte Carlo have the same slope but the
slope is better than what you get with
thermal simulated annealing so again
what if we were to compare combined this
say with better hard work now these
results have a problem and the problem
is the following these so-called
frustrated cluster loops again our
logical problem defined on a planar
lattice and what this means is you're
optimizing a planar spin glass problem
in other words this is bad news because
you can solve this action in polynomial
time so if I take the same results now
and I use minimum weight perfect
matching on them and comparing up to the
solver we used take the d-wave data
which are colored here in yellow and
this is our solver note that the axis
changed from linear log to log log and
you can see that we are exponentially
faster than actually the d-wave so you
got to be careful when you make these
claims and especially if you read all
these press releases I would take them
with a giant grain of salt good
I would say 2:1 for classical now in the
last couple of minutes that I have I'd
like to talk about something that is a
keen grin for machine learning and this
is fair sampling something that is very
important to me what is first sampling
it's the ability of an algorithm to find
uncorrelated solution ideal our
solutions to a degenerate problem
ideally with the same probability why is
this important well sometimes the
solutions are more important than the
optimum think of hashtag think of
probabilistic membership filters based
on Sat or machine learning applications
and sometimes some solutions might be
more convenient to external constraints
that were not considered to simplify the
problem so when you benchmark an
algorithm a good benchmark is can I find
the optimum fast and reliably a much
harder one is can I find all minimizing
configurations and back in 2009 oh and I
should say again our solver turns out to
be one of the fair samplers out there
that we could find today so back in 2009
we decided to study a 5 variable type
problem again here solid means variables
want to be the same - means they want to
be an opposite values and you can
actually go and integrate the
Schrodinger equation you can do the
whole simulated quantum annealing study
and what you will find is that state 1
is exponentially suppressed this is
probability of finding the state as a
function of time in states two and three
appear 50% of the time and this is kind
of a bad sign if there is a state that
you can never find in your quantum
evolution
well what about quantum annealing
machines we went in we designed problems
very carefully that I have a very well
curated number of ground states and we
then ran this algorithm many many times
or these for many times on the quantum
annealer and what you will see in the
next slide is if there its first
sampling you would expect to find a
histogram that is roughly flat Motocross
on fluctuations if the sampling is
unfair you would expect something like
that briefly show you the data as you
can see this is a logarithmic scale this
was run on a quantum annealer by D wave
and you can see that if you do quantum
annealing with a transverse field your
mass is a bias in other words you will
need to tweak transfer field quantum
dealing if you want to use a quantum
annealer for sampling good with this I'd
like to slowly come to an end I think it
doesn't look too good
but I want to emphasize that this is for
analog quantum annealing on current
hardware ok this makes a lot of
assumptions as to what the quality of
the hardware is and I archives recently
started a program based on quantum
enhancer optimization you can wait five
years find out if better qubits will
give you better results or maybe by then
we will be superseded by digital devices
such as the ones being worked on by
Microsoft and we just elect to finish
hopefully I'll be able to show you that
classical optimization pushes quantum
developments but at the same time
quantum developments leverage classical
new algorithms that are very fast and
much better than the things that we've
been using for a long time in physics
machine learning could benefit from
quantum annealing if we can teach it to
sample fairly and finally today there is
no real application speed-up that has
been found so far
we can still squash any quantum annealer
with classical hardware thank
[Applause]
great thank you thank you helmet and
let's use to Nathan can you come on
great so now we have time we have about
20 minutes for questions we've heard
I'll start with a question and then
we'll open it up to the audience we have
runners on the sides here with mics so
if you have a question feel free to
raise your hand early and they can get a
mic to you
thank you all for wonderful talks we
covered a large space we've covered
everything from using machine learning
to learn about quantum physics itself
and then in the end looking all the way
to actually maybe having classical
approaches that he'll perform
quantum approaches and cases and then
hearing more about digital solutions
from Nathan during the second talk you
know where else do you think we can
learn from these quantum methods from
quantum mechanics and quantum algorithms
to see improvements in classical machine
learning and AI applications well I mean
one of the things that at least we've
run into in the past with some of our
some of our work is that sometimes there
actually are solutions that you need
creative solutions that you need to come
up with at least on the a quantum
algorithms side in order to be able to
kind of fit the problems that we
naturally are but we want to follow the
machine learning to a quantum computing
setting and that forces you to sometimes
try some unorthodox approaches to
sampling and other algorithms and
sometimes just forcing yourself to look
down very unorthodox paths that things
can we need very different solutions
that have very different use cases than
the standard methods that are being
employed so that's that's one way which
I found that it been helpful to us yeah
I think we saw nicely in elmo's talk how
competitions from quantum devices
the people built already makes people
think about the new approaches next
people look back at how did we do mega
statistically in piety metal 3 in in the
past and now that the new generation
telecare architected methods so this
green one is actually extremely good
news for the field that that by the
quantum competition the only one we have
made huge progress in classical
technology that's useful immediately
while we wait for the quantum machine to
be be ready and just this quantum
viewpoint can give you new ideas
significance idea terrific and so in
terms of you know in the last talk
resource book mostly about analog
devices what do you see is the power of
the digital quantum computer what could
it gain over for example these these
methods we saw and helmets talk at the
end well I mean I think that I think
that the obvious big advantage of
digital devices is that you can err
correct them so there's all other the
questions that you were raising about
the noise for example in the couplers in
the d-wave system and how those can
impact the quality of solutions with
digital approaches at least in principle
even if you wanted to do Vakili the same
thing you could at least use error
correction to make those qualities
arbitrarily good on top of that the
other thing that having a digital device
allows you allows you to do or at least
a gate based device that's universal is
it allows you to really I think bring to
bear for one improve quantum sampling
techniques that can give you a quadratic
improvement on the number of samples you
need to take from the system like a
amplitude estimation for example the
other thing is you can you can apply
quantum simulation which allows you to
simulate and apply physics models that
can't be employed on classical or you
know your classical I like a stochastic
amel Tony like you see Indy way so I
think those commuters and
I agree that basically analog machines
have a limited set of applications they
were built in this particular case just
to optimize and you can always cast any
other problem as an optimization problem
but that is not going to scale in the
long run and I guess the best way to
summarize why we should look at digital
versus another is why should I buy a
better max if I can buy a blu-ray DVD
that's basically what it boils down to
great are there questions in the
audience let's open it up to a couple
mark Hill I'm at a University of
Wisconsin and also with the computer
community consortium so this latter
organization is about catalyzing
research by getting researchers research
funders and research customers together
with all that's happening in the
industry what what you see that there's
more opportunity to catalyze research in
quantum computing or is all going as
fast as you can that's lots of
opportunity because what we do at the
company is that we want to take
something that people have shown exist
can be done and you want to scale it up
that needs message they fit to get the
divestment in the city of engineering
cause you always need new ideas we need
new ideas for new hardware we need new
ideas for new algorithms new
applications so we always need people to
come up and bring new ideas and once we
have a condo computer we need people to
use it to learn how to program it so Amy
so this just makes the feels much much
bigger than before so another question
in front hi I'm Phil Dominguez from the
University of Washington if it's hard to
design quantum mechanical versions of
neural networks because quantum
mechanics is linear and you'll networks
are nonlinear why not use quantum field
theory
okay so that's a very good question one
of the big problems with quantum field
theory is that at least you know if you
take a look at the we've got a few that
we can actually we know we can simulate
in quantum computers but in general we
actually don't know that we can
efficiently simulate all field theories
for example we don't have a rigorous
proof that we can simulate the standard
model efficiently on a quantum computer
we strongly believe for aesthetic
reasons that it's likely true but it's
very difficult for us to begin with a
Lagrangian formulation like you normally
do with a field theory and then
translate that over to a series of
quantum gates that we can execute and I
think that solving that problem is an
important open question in quantum
computing and in quantum simulation but
in general we don't we don't know really
how to effectively deal with this and
one of the issues is that this actually
we actually even have some cases some
no-go theorems because if you've got two
quantum state vectors that are nearly
parallel to each other and those are the
inputs to your algorithm we have bounds
that say you need a minimum number of
copies of this state that depend on the
overlap of the inner product between the
two with a strong non-linearity we can
separate those two so if we could
actually implement that physically we
violate these lower bound and yet we
have a contradiction so what needs to be
done to some extent if we want to kind
of implement these nonlinearities from a
ground up is really kind of sort of need
to do them I feel on the classical end
before we feed them into our quad
computer so we should use classical
computers for what they're good at
ie nonlinearities and we should use the
quantum device for what is good at
linear algebra and and sampling great
there other questions in the audience
oh yes there's one in the back in the
middle oh okay we'll start here and then
we'll go to the back Chris hi thanks to
the talks I'm Kristen water Microsoft
Research cryptography I wondered about
your comment about using quantum
computers in a positive way to help
protect privacy we're all used to
quantum attacks on polynomial quantum
attacks on the traditional crypto system
so I wondered what you meant by that
sure yeah I didn't I didn't
unfortunately have time to go into this
so there's a number of different ways we
can do this one way a lot of these stem
from the original idea of quantum key
distribution which allows us to you know
to be able to communicate in a perfectly
secure way without making any
cryptographic assumptions between two
parties starting is a small amount of
random T to begin with but the key point
is is that what what you can do is you
can do things like a blind quantum
computing which allow us to do something
very similar to Alma morphic encryption
but it's not protected by complexity
assumptions about the cryptography it
really is honestly protected by the laws
of quantum physics so we can use this in
order to securely in order to secure our
training data and apply an ml algorithm
but recent work that we've done has
actually shown you can do tasks using
very similar reasoning like k-means
clustering in a private fashion where
you can bound the maximum amount of
information about any the ownership of
any training vector that's submitted to
the algorithm so for example you could
learn mean an adversary can learn means
in principle out of this but they could
never learn whose medical data they
contributed to a quantum classifier and
so these are the sorts of things we can
play and we can use the fact that
anytime you measure a quantum system in
general you disturb it in order to limit
the impact that an adversary can have
without being affected great question in
the back
yes hello David Blaine restitch abode so
you've compared the performance of the
d-wave machine with you know optimized
classical algorithms but the d-wave
machine is an analog device so as anyone
compared it with an analog classical
computer we're in the process of doing
that right now actually we got our hands
on - it's a digital machine but it can
be run in a semi analog bulk with
limited position and we're doing that us
as I'm speaking right now there so I
have one addition here namely you can
run that machine slightly warmer that is
basically exactly Anila so you can run
the machine in a classical mode when you
do that my particular is that for most
problems it may even be better than when
we you are making the quantum mode so
you have to pick the best algorithm for
the application but they use the quantum
or classical and let machine if you buy
one you can change the template and you
can run it in both actually if I may add
to that so if you allow more random
fluctuations in temperature you get
better sampling of states - so if you
use the machine not in the way it's
intended it turns out to be a better
sampler then when you think you're doing
it with quantum mechanics thank you
great are there other questions in the
audience
it's not I'll ask another question so
we've spoken about analog to digital
devices when we look at the early
digital quantum computers what do you
think those key first applications will
be I think I think that the key first
applications are likely going to be the
things that most closely match the
hardware that we have and from that
perspective at least with with the sorts
of technologies we're looking at at
Microsoft I honestly think simulation is
likely going to be the first application
because it just so naturally matches the
physics of the devices that we're going
to have I think that then once we go
beyond simulation as Mattias pointed out
in his life once we push towards the
couple
and qubit range then we can do things
like the quantum Boltzmann machines that
I talked about on a bigger scale but one
thing that I think is actually kind of
evocative that we could do on a much
smaller scale is we could use
technologies like this try to understand
our quantum Hardware in a slightly
faster way than what we could do with
our classical Hardware it's not looking
for a big speed up with this device but
just some understanding of what's going
on in the quantum system and that could
give us information we need in order to
design better quantum computers which
give us better quantum AIS which give us
better quantum computers and the hope
would be to use this to in a virtuous
cycle to bootstrap on top of each other
to give us really the devices we want to
be able to do things like quantum NMS
anything they're just having game oisin
with the hundred good qubits we'll let
the play with eight explore to learn
your things invent new algorithms the
since plane was students and it will
have a big impact so the application
will be learning understanding and
training and who knows these machines
with about 200 or 200 with a bigger than
anything we can simulate on earth so
there may be lots of potential in there
for AI that we have to find it the gap I
agree I think that the first
developments of small-scale content and
digital quantum devices will be
basically tore computers to develop new
algorithms on them which is I think work
where most of the development right now
is needed so as we think about these in
the development of toy algorithms on
these small devices it reminds me that
we're sitting at the faculty summit
where we have many people from academic
departments in the audience thinking
about educating the next generation of
quantum physicists and quantum computer
scientists and machine learning
theorists and practitioners you know how
do we go about training and teaching to
this new way of programming and
designing algorithms that are hybrid in
nature between classical and quantum
when I talk to my colleagues when they
tell me that actually my
is doing the community a big disfavor by
grabbing me here so what we have to do
is we have to keep - let me keep
teaching people we have to bring in
people here with to make tools - the
available to others we have to share our
knowledge with others and we have to
invite others to join us so I agree with
material that you know the company that
has the means to actually make really
big developments in fast pace it would
be great to see more you know
open-source tools and also access to
potential devices and to have academics
play with and teach with but as somebody
who is in a physics department I always
have to explain people that what I do is
physics because continuously until well
you're not a physicist and I think that
one of the biggest barriers right now in
teaching this in an academic environment
is the fact that there's a balkanization
between computer science engineering
physics mathematics and so
interdisciplinary centers need to be
created and companies like Microsoft
could leverage such centers of
institutions to basically foster the
teaching of these new discipline
excellent one thing I think really we
really need is that we some we really
need to also create the art of quantum
computer programming I mean so far what
we have is our main resource in this is
a textbook that at present is over a
decade old and doesn't have many of the
new innovations or many of the new
tricks at present if somebody wants to
learn how to say employ a
state-of-the-art a quantum simulation
algorithm then there's an entire chain
of papers that they have to go through
and learn in an idiosyncratic fashion
and we haven't figured out the right way
to consolidate and communicate these
tools and concepts so that people can
rapidly learn and I think we really need
to do that in order to actually really
start leveraging all the knowledge that
special
yes I could point Helmut maybe I also
did not fit in well at ETH people in
Philly didn't think and physicists they
were not sure but I'm an experimentalist
or an engineer or whether I'm in
computer science and what's great here
at Microsoft is that nobody even asks
you what you are so it can be all of
that I think that's something that we
should bring back when we break down the
barriers between fields because what you
need in quantum computing you need
physics knowledge mathematics
computational science yes computer
science algorithms you do needed all its
engineering and science we have to take
down barriers and and make the ha it was
open so I often get the question from
undergraduate students you know what
should I do if I want to work in the
field what is your recommendation to
them get a PhD in what get a PhD really
I mean I think that one of the things is
that getting a PhD in physics computer
science or mathematics that those can be
great in some cases even getting a
degree in you know chemistry can be fine
the key thing is I think in all of those
areas it's really increasingly important
to learn the tools that other that have
been developed about the field I think
that we can't get by just by limiting
ourselves to one particular area if we
want to really honestly be good at
quantum sciences so you know you need to
get a PhD more importantly than you need
to get a PhD I feel in a particular
field from a plant
that assumes that you have faculty
members that understand the
interdisciplinary interdisciplinary
nature needed to get a PhD that will
serve you later for working in that
field so I you know I have one student
here he's slouching in his chair over
there
and I think from what I've heard
discussions with them likely you know
being able to be an intern for example
at Microsoft where you can learn from
all these fields at once is probably key
in start to build up for a degree in
that direction is there any are there
any final questions from the audience
it's not I'll ask one more question what
are you most excited about seeing in
this field kind of at the intersection
of quantum computing and AI nml in the
next few years when I started doing
science I didn't know what to study but
I just knew I wanted to do science with
great new computers and just having
something totally amazing it different
than you for doing anything in science
is exciting and then we'll find out what
who so first and what second about third
I mean the things that I'm most
interested in there are two things the
first is I think that when it comes to
quantum computing we've really have for
a long time dramatically under
underutilized machine learning in
actually figuring out ways to calibrate
and characterize our quantum systems
these tools started coming into into use
but we really haven't fully leveraged
them and I'm very excited within the
next few years to see what some of these
new developments in particular ideas
like reinforcement learning might end up
giving us in error correction or in
other areas but conversely I'm also
curious to see what quantum machine
learning ideas can give us in terms of
characterizing physical systems
themselves it seems that there's a great
potential to use one too into quantum
system in order to interrogate another
quantum system and do experiments that
we wouldn't be able to otherwise carry
out and so I'm very excited to start
seeing real experiments of that form
being pink for coming I've always been
very interested in solving hard problems
and in the past you know you could say
well who cares about who were doing but
it was hard that was what
what really interested me and I've come
to realize in the last few years mostly
because of this field that there's a lot
of problems out there in the real world
that are hard and that need to be solved
and I think that both AI and quantum are
tools that will allow us to solve these
hard problems much easier in the near
future on that note please help me in
thanking our speakers again for a
wonderful session and thank you all for
attending today